the bootleg capture from the vmas 40.3
on 88.3 we're hip five lives the bootleg
capture we broadcasting live oh yeah
VMAs 2012 style we big showing up in
here what's up man chillin brothers is
nice to finally see you it's been a
minute since we saw each other yeah I
know man we homies though yeah of course
uh I had you come through the studio of
course man please all about a row we
time right now that are WT that's right
yeah like that I love that record ma'am
and that's that's a fun record a shout
out to you for throwing robbing the
video in the in the Jeep rockin it was
player dude yeah for people who don't
know the person was in a jeep with me
and he was in that 24 carats ago sniff
it too that's my engineer man who got me
you know I'm saying sound or right and
cocaine 80 swag cocaine you do cocaine
heirs of course you know so it's fun man
we have fun with it today's the day bro
Detroit is coming out uh oh you hours
two hours like a lock right yeah I can't
wait for to come out I know you I you
have to be politically correct but I
just can't wait for everybody stop
talking about that terrible wayne
mixtape I could say that I can't wait
for the mixtape man how many tracks on
it um 15 tracks 15 tracks and three
skits plus three scoots it's gonna be I
know I probably heard some of the stuff
on there yeah but you got to hear the
album I got the album's done i'm just
working on my last two songs for the
album so this is setting up the album
nicely perfect so we got Detroit when is
a time soon we get that that second
sophomore album bro are you getting at
this year you get in the end of year
fourth quarter at the very end of the
year the label need it I got it you got
it I can working on a minute here we
gonna drop the single soon you know we
dropping that click song tomorrow yeah
that's on a good music album but it's
also on my album too okay yes that's me
cayenne jay z but we'll be dropping a
single off my album like this month it's
been all good lately you were just did
the performance with the entire squad
out at the the made in America festival
man what was that like is that the first
time y'all all were on stage together at
once with 2 Chainz included
seemed like we did it somewhere else I
can't remember but that was one of the
that was definitely one of the main ones
you know what I'm saying that was a even
just you know you think of when I was
looking at Debra when I was looking at
bad boy they said in big productions
even early Rockefeller you know what I'm
saying it was just tied to be a part of
that and I feel like that's what the we
were to what they were to me to like a
new generation of fans you guys are that
new squad man is a beautiful thing it's
a more walking off the stage you know
everybody walked off together J yay yay
was like man I'm happy I'm sure i'm glad
you rapping me at that radio station man
i see his [__] me to the right and it
all started by you walking up to gain
spitting that verse for my and it's just
you know sir testament of hard work and
just about everybody i've been hopping
on songs with i met before and they know
who i was and i was trying to like let
them know trying to get them on some and
then I made them turn around and come
asked me to be on a song with them
something now you guys doing man I do
have a title for the second album it no
i don't i was in the studio with jeezy
like a few days ago Aziz was like how
you got mo co album done I got it today
got a title I guess he don't work like
that he works out of the way he comes up
with the title and in her music I just
feel like it's gonna pop pop up when
it's time a second album um from what I
heard man it sounds like it's gonna be a
classic dog i really i really can't wait
for the people to hear what you got the
store yeah i think so man this mixtape
I'm about to drop though Detroit that
I'm dropping right now is it's better
than a lot of people's albums on us I
you a lot of your man you know I said I
know cocky director I won't even be on
that type of [__] or whatever but it's
just like it really is pretty good
though it's pretty good pretty damn good
pretty damn good man and I and I really
work hard you know I really put in I
work every day I can man straight up
what's up yeah the cliq joint is crazy
dropping tomorrow as a click away how is
its click right yeah click OK yeah yeah
and um that's crazy how that came about
was this when we did mercy was in the
studio just coming up ideas and I came
up with I did I heard the beat came up
with it immediately in like a couple
minutes
I did averse to it later and I'm sent it
to ya and didn't hear anything for a
couple months and then a couple months
later I get a call I yeah man Jay might
be hopping on it and I was like oh damn
it's great him and it was like Jan yay
hopped on it and I was like oh so they
taken a record you know I do nevery yeah
and then it was like no you want it like
you're holding your own with yay and
hold on the same joint yeah that's
that's incredible I like yeah man that's
crazy dream come true brother it's
exciting to see that come full circle so
I'm going to kind of tough time with my
family so it's just tight to see all
that come through and you know gives
everybody strengthen you know support so
it's great can you let us know any any
features on the on besides of course the
obvious that we just talked about uh it
was some good ones and I don't know got
some good ones can you give us one nos
nos nos on the album nozzle album that's
beautiful okay so y'all can look forward
to a nas a big hunter in collaboration
produced by no ID yes oh yeah that's
what I'm talking about definitely I want
to let you get going minutes busy you
got other radio stations yes sir I
appreciate you having me man you know we
brothers so yeah for sure or gonna get
it in Big Sean get the mixtape it comes
out in two hours on Detroit download
that man is me you know you got Jake
hold on there you got Kendrick on there
you got everybody on there the mac
miller make it not me my really did a
song I heard that record that's my homie
though no big sean com get it right
there there right there yeah our 98.3
live from the vmas a big Sean let's go
there